oh I've never talked about this and I
watch the show and I always wanted to
talk about on the podcast do you guys
watch the narcos do you why you laughing
dude narcos okay look first of all the
guy who plays [ __ ] Pablo Escobar on
narcos I'm telling you right now that's
the best acting I've seen in years dude
he's Pablo Escobar and I don't even mean
he's the real Pablo Escobar I mean he
created a [ __ ] character even though
there's a real Pablo Escobar
he made this guy on TV Pablo Escobar
maybe he's not like the real Pablo
Escobar doesn't matter that guy in his
head is literally thinking I'm not the
actor I'm this guy but then he forgets
that and just as that guy that acting
that that guy does as Pablo Escobar has
not been seen since like early Robert De
Niro [ __ ] I mean he's so good dude he is
so [ __ ] good and there is and I love
that I love the show it takes a little
bit getting into because the [ __ ]
voice-over dude did they use the
voice-over they have the guy the white
guy whatever the [ __ ] that guy is who
played the bad guy in the the Logan
movie whatever his name is
who the voiceover everybody's good but
the voiceover like all this guy talks
about is hey we like every it's the most
unnecessary voiceover that's the thing I
don't get about that show is it could
just be the show now there's a thing in
writing and in screenwriting where they
say like any you can make any movie
without the voiceover and it's better if
you don't but all the best movies that
you ever [ __ ] have watched have
voiceover on it so it's kind of like
it's kind of like a [ __ ] thing like
you they say in screenwriting when you
when you learn it like you never need to
have a voiceover you can always like but
voice all the best movies have
voiceovers on it I can't even think of
one right now
Goodfellas as far back as I can remember
I always wanted to be a gangster and
then Beanie Sigel put it on his album
and he started do rappers
[ __ ] Italian gangster [ __ ] man you
seen too many movies that's why Tupac
said that but no when [ __ ] beanie
sigel came out with an album he took us
to he like took a page from the good
fella says and he says as far as back as
I could remember I always want to be a
gangster as far as back he says hey
Saddam as far back as I remember I could
always want it to be a gangster but Boyd
what's his name
Boyd is that the guy Donald Pierce oh no
no that's him yet
that's the narcos guy right so he's good
I'm not saying he's not good but he's
good in the [ __ ] show he's great but
I like the guy he's awesome
the voice-over dude is hilarious though
it's unnecessary and it's said
describing it's like it's like what
narcos didn't know was we were two steps
ahead of them well what the narcos
didn't know was we were we were always
two steps ahead of him but then what we
didn't realize was that the narcos were
four steps behind us so we had to go six
steps back now in Miami two steps were
way different than what it was down in
Colombia
we were we were used to two steps in
Miami but two steps in Colombia was
technically one and a half steps due to
the elevation and drug trafficking we
had to do math and make sure that every
one and a half steps we took was
actually two steps this is the way we
got ahead of the narcos and you're just
like uh
okay it's just showing [ __ ] scrolling
shots of like cocoa leaves Pablo asked
I didn't realize as we had him right
where we wanted but what we didn't
realize was that Pablo had us right
where he wanted before that so what we
had to do was jockey around and move
positions without letting him know but
also we had to keep him right where we
wanted and that was how we got the jump
on narcos but we got the jump on them
but what we didn't realize was that they
were underwater and you can't jump in
water so what we had to do was you
guessed it drain the narcos pool and
you're just like uh
okay and then they [ __ ] stabbed
somebody in the face and you're like oh
she was good you see we didn't realize
that the narcos had private jets and
they were taking the all the all the
coke from one area to another so when we
got to the area they were already
somewhere else and even though we had
him right where we want it we realized
one thing where we wanted wasn't
actually where we needed uh then they
[ __ ] stabbed somebody in the [ __ ] and
make him eat it you see the narcos were
funny not funny like haha but the kind
of funny will you just sit back and you
look and think damn that's funny so
taking two steps every one and a half
steps and the elevation taken into
account because Columbia was a lot lower
than Miami we were used to three feet
above sea level but where the narcos
were or ten feet below sea level so what
we had to do was get taller guys oh you
see when the narcos came it changed
everything everything from buying
selling the government killing winning
baseball shirts running aliens sky and
all those things were two steps ahead of
us and then somebody gets [ __ ] shot
in the [ __ ] eye you see what the
narcos didn't know was that's every
[ __ ] in the beginning of every
monologue in the voice-over you see what
we didn't know you see what the narcos
didn't know was you see what paul didn't
remember you see what my wife didn't
realize was you see what the
one-year-old baby we just adopted from
the narcos didn't know was googoo gaga
[Laughter]
now the baby said googoo gaga we didn't
know what he meant
but what we didn't realize was the
narcos knew exactly what Baby Talk was
so we got an informant we got someone
who could understand baby talk and his
name was poison we got poison talking to
that baby baby would say googoo gaga -
poison and poison would ship 20 kilos
back to Miami that's how the operation
was we had him right where we wanted and
then they [ __ ] stretched someone's
limb so hard that their shoulders come
out of their sockets the voice-over a
narcos dude [ __ ] we all had sneakers on
I feel like that in the middle of that
show there could be a voiceover where
the guy just for no reason said we all
had sneakers on during this scene and
you just would literally not even
realize it and you'd be and then they'd
[ __ ] somebody would like [ __ ] like
rape someone and then stab them in the
head and then you'd be like wow this
shows [ __ ] gritty
you notice the narcos wearing sneakers
we all had sneakers oh no get away from
me No it shows gritty that guy is blue
eyes